the justice secretary deputy prime
minister dominic rabb joins us on in the
studio good to see you this morning good
morning and i i i do promise we will get
to your brief in a few minutes time but
there's an awful lot around ukraine we
need to discuss we
we heard yesterday the us secretary of
defense lloyd austin saying that ukraine
believes it can win the war we've just
been speaking to our correspondent in
the donbass saying that forces there
believe they can win the war boris
johnson when he was in india struck a
note of caution suggesting that russia
might win is are we the voice of reason
in all of this or or perhaps is boris
johnson just parking some of the
boosterism when it comes to ukraine well
i think we want to show maximum
solidarity to ukraine but it's clear
that the conflict is in the balance
i've said since the first time i came on
sky news i didn't think it would be over
in weeks possibly not even in months so
we need the strategic stamina and
staying power and i think the prime
minister is very conscious of that so we
keep ramping up the pressure on putin
through the sanctions we keep supporting
as best we can with military hardware
and others support the ukrainians and we
do the most we can to deter
putin's behaviour i spoke to the icc
prosecutor yesterday we're rallying
countries to support the investigation
not just because we want to see justice
done for any war crimes we want to send
a deterrent message now to those
commanders in the field that if they
commit war crimes they'll end up behind
bars but just to pick up on something as
you yourself admit you've said before
not over in weeks and months you know
we could potentially be looking in into
the years certainly over 12 months in
terms of our involvement let's trust
your colleague the foreign secretaries
is making a really important speech
later on today in which she's going to
suggest that that two percent nato
spending target or on defense
should be the floor not the ceiling i
mean just in terms of the length of the
mission with our current spending how
sustainable is it for the uk and other
nations to keep sending arms with the
temple that we already have well that's
why we need the strategic stamina we're
one of the few countries that meets the
nato
target and i think there's long been
this argument and you've heard it from
successive american administrations that
some european countries need to step up
to the plate we agree with that
and at the same time we need to think
if this is going to last months possibly
years how we keep supporting at the
right pace the ukrainian resistance
which has been so sorry to interrupt but
it sounds like you kind of agree with
liz trust i mean when she refers to two
percent as as the floor not the ceiling
certainly suggests that liz trust is
minded to see a significant increase in
defence spending here
and that view is not universally held
around the cabinet table as i understand
it well no that we've seen a massive
increase in defense spending uh the
chancellor uh and the defense sector
worked very closely under the leadership
of the prime minister on that obviously
we've got a cost of living crisis we
need to cut our coats according to our
cloth overall but actually the direction
of travel has been to boost
and change the nature of our defenses
because of course then you can see this
in ukraine you can see this in terms of
russia as an adversary it's not just
conventional warfare we're seeing we've
also got cyber misinformation we need to
adapt to that that's exactly what the
chancellor and defense secretary have
done but the chancellor didn't do the
last opportunity that he did have did he
in the spring statement not by my record
all right
no no but we just had a spending review
we had a strategic uh uh defense uh
review uh an integrated review in
foreign policy that was absolutely the
right time to take a long-term forward
look and the chance that absolutely
along with the defense secretary
addressed this there just in terms
though of of what we are hearing from
the russians
by my measure i think this is the first
time that russia has made a direct
threat against the united kingdom
yesterday james he your colleague at the
mod said it was completely legitimate
for ukraine to seek out russian targets
to disrupt their logistics the russians
have responded saying well if you do
that if you keep encouraging them you
now become a legitimate target what do
you feel about that well the russian
statement is unlawful and what we're
doing is lawful international law is
very clear on this we're entitled all
states are entitled to provide military
support to any state exercising the
right of lawful defense against an
aggressive invasion and frankly if
russia starts threatening other
countries it only adds
further to their pariah status and will
only further the if you like solidarity
and the consensus of the international
community that they must be stopped
just before you can we've heard this
morning poland has had the gas cut off
we would assume therefore that
bulgaria will will follow quickly it
will quickly follow suit what can we do
to assist them because it does look like
poland is going to be in an awful lot of
trouble without that kind of energy well
i mean first of all we need to show
solidarity clearly what we are seeing is
the need to wean ourselves off uh
reliance on russia we've obviously got
very low reliance on gas from russia i
think it's around three percent uh
though some european countries in a
different position we have been warning
about this for a while but yes we'll
stand uh shoulder to shoulder with our
polish friends and allies they've said
that they can deal with this but of
course it will have a delete a very
damaging effect on russia as well
because it is becoming further and
further more and more not just a
political prior but an economic prior
and that will put the squeeze ultimately
on vladimir putin but one thing is true
and clear we cannot allow his bullying
behavior whether it's economic warfare
uh or its military warfare to succeed
can we just briefly then to return to
the to the mail on sunday article um
about angela raynor
we understand that the whips have been
taking a look into all of this i mean
here's the the the piece itself i mean i
don't i probably don't even need to ask
what your response is to the piece
itself i think i probably know but no
it's terrible and uh i i go up
occasionally against angela rainer in my
position as deputy prime minister uh
she's a formidable opponent i respect
her entirely and i can't stand this kind
of thing so has that have the whips
gotten anywhere closer to who was
responsible for all of this well i i i'd
need to speak to the chief whip about
this is something that he will be
looking at and of course it's very
difficult to find but what we're clear
is that we don't tolerate um we will not
tolerate any behavior and uh smear like
this and if we can find out we will take
action against it i i wonder what you
make of the the editor of the mail on
sunday's refusal to attend that meeting
he was invited by the speaker of the
house of commons
and the daily mail today being being
rather punchy i have to say about it no
mr speaker they're invoking the freedom
of the press i suppose the other view in
all of this says what was to be lost by
turning up
at the speaker's office and having a
conversation about this look i think uh
whether it's the speaker or the the
newspaper editors we all believe in two
things one the power and the importance
of free speech but secondly the
importance of not allowing that to be
abused and
and used to spread sexism in any shape
or form
i'm not going to second guess the the
the decision makers by decisions of
editors
it's his current common speaker should
the common speaker then have invited i
think it was a legitimate thing for
lindsay hall do to invite him and of
course it's the prerogative of any
editor to decide how they treat that
invitation um everyone yesterday at
cabinet was asked to come up with some
bright ideas for the cost of living
crisis i'm just wondering what yours
were sitting at at the head of the
justice department we look at um i don't
comment on the detail of what we discuss
in cabinet but i think there's a whole
range of things uh that we're looking at
first of all we've got a 22 billion
pound package to deal with the cost of
living but this prime minister and this
chance are going to be absolutely
assiduous and relentless in looking at
what more we can do we're providing
rebates on uh council tax on energy
bills we've got this pot of money that
local authorities can use to target the
most vulnerable and but we look as is
well known we discussed child care one
of the things there's lots of former
housing ministers around the cabinet
table we've discussed housing costs
these are all areas where we're never
going to stop we're going to continue
unflinchingly to look at what more we
can do and the reason being is we
understand the pressure that families up
and down the country around you
understand the kind of the knee jerk
response when you know the papers are
carrying stories that grant chaps big
bright idea was you know making annual
mot tests come you know biannually you
know torsten bell from the resolution
foundation says if this is the answer
then the government has lost the plot i
suppose the problem for you is if you
have all these individual policies and
you bring them together and you total
them up then eventually it may well be
that we see that the cost of living
crisis ameliorated somewhat but there's
no one big measure like the labour party
has the windfall tax which would see an
immediate kind of cash injection first
of all i don't agree in terms of the
characterization the conservative
policies the uc taper saves the relevant
families a thousand pounds a year um if
you look at what we've done on the
national living wage that saves a
thousand pounds a year for those
eligible full-time workers and frankly
if you look at labour's policy you asked
about it of a windfall tax that would
damage investment in energy supplies we
need and hike bills it's disastrous it's
not serious so what this shows is
they're coming up with frankly uh ill
thought through policies but we've got a
plan a concerted plan and i think that's
what voters want to see uh minister i am
nothing if not a man of your word so
let's talk about europe
and one has to say a fairly significant
announcement about the way we tackle
radicalization within our prisons tell
us more so look the the changing threat
from terrorism uh evolves all the time
but it's also evolving in prisons why
because we're locking up more terrorists
and extremists than ever before 200
convicted prisoners convicted of
terrorist offences another 200 prisoners
who've got terrorist links jonathan hall
has conducted this independent report we
accept it pretty much in full
and we got to do more to prevent
extremists tainting the well let me give
you two brief illustrations one we must
nip in the bud far earlier the kind of
coercive controlling behavior by
extremists which can lead to
radicalization and terrorism just to
give a concrete example of course we
want to respect the right for prisoners
to be able to eat halal prepare food
allow but they can't have no-go areas in
kitchens for those who don't respect or
comply with their rules secondly we've
got these separation centers which are
used to isolate the most dangerous
radicalizing recruiters of uh
of terrorists we need to probably make
greater use of that so i'm beefing up
the money to target those offenders who
need to be removed and finally we'll
need this bill of rights to replace the
human rights act to stop the legal
attrition that we're already starting to
see with terrorism extremists claiming a
right to socialize within prison when
what actually they want to do is
radicalize it sounds to me that that
last part is the most important part in
all of this if the kind of the mantra
that we hear from government about
activist lawyers is true and you would
certainly expect when you start bringing
in some of these changes for there to be
challenges all the way to the supreme
court well we've already had it we've
got a number of cases uh we've had to
it's cost us half a million pounds uh to
defend these cases we've not been taken
to court yet
but what i want to do is is put the
policies in place to protect the public
i think we have allowed understandable
uh cultural and religious sensitivities
to deter us as jonathan hall sets out
and of course what the bill of rights
will do is while respecting our
fundamental freedoms make sure we've got
the common sense balance and in this
context allowing prison governors to
take the action they need to retain the
security in the prison but also to
protect the public from these very
dangerous people great to have you in
the studio thank you